[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar light field microscopy camera
solutions i am sabrina of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by teledyne photometrics to learn
more visit photometrics.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speakers
professor liang gao associate professor
department of bioengineering at ucla
professor shujia assistant professor
the wallace h coulter department of
biomedical engineering dr phil allen
product manager teledyne photometrics
and dr matthew cosey dunn contact
content manager at teledyne photometrics
professor gao professor gia dr allen and
dr jose dunn you may now begin your
presentation
hello and welcome to a teledyne
photometrics webinar all about light
field microscopy and how to obtain 3d
images in just a single acquisition
we're going to go over what lightfield
microscopy is as well as the benefits
challenges and applications
this is all supported by two guest
speakers who frequently make use of
lifefield microscopy and followed up by
my colleague on the kinetics scmos
family for lightfield as well as some
new kinetics modes that are going to be
a big help for advanced imaging users
everywhere
first a bit about who we are at teledyne
photometrics
we design and manufacture high
sensitivity cameras for challenging
scientific imaging
so we have a range of solutions to match
a range of applications all the way from
things like single molecule imaging to
fast dynamic techniques like voltage
imaging
we're the market leader for scientific
cmos technologies
and we've been part of the teledyne
imaging group since 2019
on this webinar will be myself dr
matthew kirzer-dunn the content manager
and application specialist for teldom
photometrics
joining me is also my colleague dr phil
allen the photometrics product manager
but most importantly also speaking on
this webinar are two guest speakers who
make frequent use of light field
microscopy and are having numerous
impacts on the field
these are professor liang gao of the
university of california and professor
xuja
of the georgia institute of technology
and emory university
firstly a bit about light field
microscopy not to be confused of
light field which is a televised
software and analysis package by the
same name
lifefield microscopy was first
introduced in 2006 by a group at the
stanford university computer graphics
lab
in light field microscopy
the entire light field within the
microscope is captured this contains
information of the radiance along the
light rays in free space which results
in a four dimensional function
termed the 4d light field
in microscopy there are numerous
techniques that exist to capture
different levels of sample
dimensionality
these are all techniques that involve
some kind of scanning and can collect
different amount of data
so firstly you have point scanning
something like multi-photon imaging
line scanning for things like confocal
and then plane scanning this can capture
entire 2d focal plane of the sample
these all involve scanning and examples
for each of these techniques are listed
below
the next level of this would be
volumetric 3d imaging where a 3d volume
can be captured in a single acquisition
this is done with light field microscopy
which is a scanless technique that
produces 3d images
the extra information in the light field
allows for additional extras such as
digital refocusing
and directionality perspective with some
deconvolution
so what is the light field
a light field is a distribution of light
or radiance from an object in this case
a microscopy sample
this light field contains intensity
positional and directional information
from the sample if the sample is dynamic
and in motion
in classic wide field or bright field
microscopy
light from a single point on the sample
is directed to a single point on the
camera
this means that the directional and
positional information from the light
field is lost
the camera mainly captures intensity
from select points on the sample
with light field microscopy
there's an additional micro lens array
before the light hits the camera sensor
this means that light from a single
point on the sample can now be directed
to different points on the camera
this allows a user to capture more of
the 4d light field from the sample from
either side of the focal plane by
splitting it onto different pixels
this allows you to get more of the 4d
light field data than the techniques
like wide field
this additional micro lens array makes a
big difference for things like axial
positioning so in wide field this is
what happens when you focus on deeper
planes beyond the focal plane
in light field the micro lens array
splits the light from the light field
resulting in distinctive non-overlapping
patterns of discrete data points from
the different focal planes
this is very useful for imaging into
thicker samples such as whole animals
tissues
or organs such as the brain
so with light field you get a 3d image
with every capture
you can determine your axial position
within a stack
and you can even use the information in
the light field
to digitally refocus your images after
you've captured them
essentially the level of data exceeds
that of typical microscopy because
you're capturing more of the 4d light
field
this also works for multiple emitters
from the same point on the sample
for wide field data from a single point
overlaps on the camera and data can be
lost from multiple point emitters
in light field
the result is a non-overlapping pattern
from each emitter within the sample and
data from both of them
can be retained
this allows you to capture more of the
light field and benefit from that extra
data
furthermore the 4d light field contains
data about the directionality of light
from different locations on the sample
thanks to capturing all the radians
these light field microscopy images can
be processed
to show the sample from different
perspectives
or to show what direction a sample is
moving in as we see here from the figure
if you image a series of particles that
are moving dynamically in solution
information from light field microscopy
can be used to tell what direction
they're moving in thanks to the multiple
perspectives of each particle that
you'll have
so in terms of applications for light
field microscopy the main one is 3d
volumetric imaging especially at high
speed
so this pairs up well with techniques
that require speed in order to capture
dynamic samples such as calcium or
voltage imaging now you can capture
functional signals from neural cells
across an entire 3d model organism such
as a c elegans nematode worm in the
figure
you can capture data from the entire
animal in 3d
all at high speed you can also use light
field for other applications such as
multi-view imaging of time of flight
signals
you can even image at extended depths
through occlusions
or image things such as non-linear
surfaces in real time
the applications and benefits of light
field expand beyond microscopy with a
whole field of light field imaging
but even when looking just at microscopy
there are numerous benefits from imaging
the light field
to summarize the benefits and challenges
of light field microscopy
for the pros you get a 3d volume with
every snapshot
you can digitally refocus these images
after you've taken them
you have increased axial resolution
and if your samples are moving around
you can also look at their
directionality thanks to the perspective
data
you can look at multiple 404s and you
can do all this at high speed
in terms of the cons or disadvantages
the additional micro lenses can result
in under sampling due to the micro lens
sometimes being larger than the camera
pixel
this can result in a decrease in lateral
resolution and potential artifacts from
the figure we can see what a raw
light field microscopy image looks like
through the microlens array however
advances in developing smaller micro
lenses a similar size to the camera
pixel would mostly eliminate this
disadvantage
the other disadvantage is that light
field microscopy generates large data
sets that require further processing
because you're capturing more of the
light field you do have more data and
you need to deconvolve or process this
data often to achieve information on
directionality
however the
generation of large data sets and their
need for further computational
processing is a very common problem
across many techniques in microscopy
but that's enough for me
let's hear from our light field
microscopy experts professors liang gao
and shuja
my name is diane gaul i'm assistant
professor at volunteering department at
ucla so my lab mainly focuses on
building light field microscopes
endoscopes all kinds of imaging
instrumentation for medical and
biological applications
my name is shuja i'm currently
assistant professor of biomedical
engineering at georgia tech and emory
university
so
our research is mainly about
biophotonics and we develop
new types of microscopy techniques
computational tools and also
imaging systems
so light field imaging is different from
dimensional echography for example for
the conventional photography imaging
somebody will only capture the light
intensity information at each spatial
pixels but for light field imaging is
capture both the spatial information and
angular information so we call it a
four-dimensional data cube and we can
using the computational imaging
techniques to transform this a
four-dimensional light field dd-cube
into a three-dimensional image
so this is actually advantage of
lighting imaging compared with the
conventional scanning based 3d imaging
approaches like this focal or
multi-photon microscopy because light
your imaging basically captured the
three-dimensional image by a single
snapshot it has a big advantage in the
imaging speed for the type of light
field microscopy we are working on
we use a array of microlenses in our
microscope which can distribute light
into different locations of the camera
sensor
which can capture both the spatial
information
and angular information of incoming
light
and we call this 2d spatial and 2d
angular solution so with this 4d light
field information computationally we can
reconstruct the full
3d volume of the object as you can see
with just the one camera frame now you
have both the spatial and angular
information so you don't really need uh
scanning in your data acquisition so
basically one camera snapshot then you
can reconstruct the full 3d volume
so that means you can really image your
object especially 3d object at very high
speed
which is primarily limited by your
camera speed
and so this is very useful especially
when you are looking at
very fast volumetric
biological information dynamics and
structures
my lab mainly focuses on trying to
further increase the imaging speed of
life in microscopy just as i mentioned
conventional lighting imaging capture is
a four dimensional data set which is
tremendous in data science because in
the live field microscopy we're still
using these conventional 2d sensors to
measure the spatial and angular
information so when the data size is
very big then the readout speed of the
cameras becomes low because these two
actually you know inversely proportional
to each other
and in my lab we're trying to using
these compressions in technique as well
as trying to correlate these different
perspective images in a live mark
microscopy and using these two methods
we can significantly reduce the detail
redundancy in the light of lifetime
microscopy so we can still keep the
image quality of this conventional light
view imaging but you know increase the
imaging speed by orders of magnitude so
our technique we call light field
tomography are short as leaf
using using this leap technology we uh
we can image you know at a treating of
frame per second for these ultra fast
imaging we can do kilohertz this kind of
frame rate for lightview microscopy
which is you know critical needed in
these neuron imaging applications what
do we enable imaging so basically we put
the mouse under our microscope and we
open a transparent window on the mouse
skull and directly access these neurons
you know using our microscope but
currently we are interested to look at
these neural activities in the deep
regions mainly in the hippocampus and we
also want to keep the mouse you know
still awake during the imaging because
anesthesia can greatly suppress this
neuron activity the sensor we use is the
gvi sensors so it's a genetically
encoded voltage sensor so for the
current workhouse of this neural imaging
people normally using the calcium
sensors like gchem but the problem is
that in the gchem is have relatively
slow corresponds
also is correlated with these neural
activities but it does not reflect every
neuron spiking events but using these
gvi sensors it
has a minutes milliseconds this is the
tempo response so we can potentially get
this in every single housing events in
every each new rounds but again this
housing event is very transient
not only at these milliseconds time
skills using conventional these light
field microscopes we cannot capture that
because the frame rate is limited by the
data size of light field and using our
approach we can just break this bottom
neck and push like filter out this
microscopy technique into the next level
so live field microscopy has now been
applied to different aspects of research
especially in
bioimaging so at a larger scale it's
been widely used for
brain imaging especially to image brain
functionality activities in real time
and also
for my lab we are particularly
interested in because this is highly
scalable we are particularly interested
to scale it down to image single cells
so now we can image the volume of single
cells
at the diffracted limit and also people
have tried to push on one hand the
spatial resolution to super resolution
and also on the other hand people have
tried to push
the reconstruction the computational
efficiency by combining
different algorithms as well as deep
learning
so
what i can see is it can be applicable
to
many different types of biological model
systems from
molecules single molecules single cells
to tissues um and also people have
imaged uh living animals so it is really
uh highly scalable so
i believe with all these developments
it will be very applicable in the future
so i think for life in microscopy the
most challenging part is ketone
redundancy as i mentioned normally that
field microscope microscope generate
tremendous size of data size so it's not
only posed a challenge on this data
transfer from the camera to the host
computer and also poses a huge challenge
on the data storage and management and
so this is why we decided to try and
look at different approaches to assess
this light field microscopy and reduce
these data during the dehydration and
improve these uh you know image
reconstruction qualities without
sacrificing this imaging speed
you can see this is a
computationally heavy technique because
now you are projecting the entire
three-dimensional information onto a
two-dimensional camera sensor so you do
have a lot of
information on a 2d image okay so how to
reconstruct your 3d information
without artifacts and with a good
computational efficiency so at the very
beginning uh when we reconstruct the 3d
volume uh
we based on a reoptics model
which of course compromised the uh
the spatial and angular information
right so that uh the micro lens array
actually limits the the spatial
resolution you can get and later on uh
people have developed a wave optics
model to reconstruct the uh the 3d
volume which considers light diffraction
as it propagates through the imaging
system so
with
better and better algorithms nowadays
we can recover
most of the information compared to for
example
ip4s microscopy whitefield or confocal
microscopy
and for our application speed is okay so
we want to image something really fast
light field microscope can give out this
3d imaging curvature but the 3d imaging
speed is still fundamentally limited by
this readout speed of the camera so this
is why we are very interested in looking
for you know these high speed cameras
which have offered is a high resolution
at the same time at its higher readout
speed
and also most importantly without these
sensors we have very low noises because
for the gvi imagings though we are
almost reached this photon short noise
limited
for each pixel we only have maybe tens
of or hundreds of photons at most so we
require these sensors to be extremely
sensitive and can be operated in these
low light conditions
so
this is why we think that you know our
current teledyne is kinetic cameras is
perfect fit for application because it's
offered is a high readout speed low
noise high sensitivity and also is
offered is a multiple region readout
functions which is also critical for
application because for our technique
we are instead of reading the full
sensor format we only read out selected
lines
and the kinect cameras is actually the
only camera on the market can offer this
function so camera is is very important
for lighting microscopy so
uh because uh the time resolution or how
fast you can image an object is just
limited by the the camera speed so as
you can see uh if you have a
larger camera sensor
well without compromising the
acquisition speed the camera frame rate
then that would be great so um so in our
setup we we we typically use scientific
cmos camera which can run at 100 hertz
or 10 millisecond
exposure time uh for the full sensor for
chip um and i mean if we want to go
faster uh for this camera we need to
compromise some of the field of view so
we need to uh reduce the lines that
that we uh that we image uh to improve
the speed
but if we can have a camera um with a
larger sensor with a higher speed uh so
that we can enhance our field of view
without losing any uh upper resolution
so that would be that would be great a
good uh aspect for live field microscopy
is uh as you can see it's uh uh you you
capture a 4d light field and then
computationally you reconstruct the 3d
volume so in this case your spatial
skills like field of view spatial
resolution is independent from your
temporal resolution okay so this is a
very good property
a lot of people call it this is highly
scalable so
because live field
microscopy can be such highly scalable
that means that if you have a larger
sensor okay you can enlarge your field
of view or enhance the
volume that you can image without losing
your speed so this is definitely a very
good a very good property to have
i think um yeah developing advanced
cameras would be
very helpful for
uh light field microscopy because this
is a type of microscopy that's highly
relying on this single camera frame so
so whatever you can contain
in a single camera frame
uh determines how much you can
reconstruct into the 3d volume so a
better camera would definitely be uh
be
helpful
to
live field microscopy so yeah we will be
very excited to to see new cameras
coming out for light film imaging
so i think a major direction for light
view imaging is to expand these
functionalities
currently light free microscopy can only
capture this light intensity in 3d image
but we want to expand this functionality
to multiplex imaging so we can capture
not only light intensity information but
also the spectral information the
polarization information and also the
fluorescence lifetime information if we
have such no huge amount of information
available can be captured you know in
combination with the light field data
acquisition then we have these very
unique capabilities to image multiple
chromophores in the same time this is
actually very important for the neuron
imaging applications because neural
scientists they are not only interested
in look at this neural housing they also
want to look at these interactions
between different neurons so these are
using different labels to label
different neuron groups and only the
image modality can offer this a
multiplex imaging capability can these
are you know imaging multiple groups of
neurons can be made possible so
regarding that as you need the multiplex
imaging is definitely a direction for
light field microscopy
on one hand people have tried to
miniaturize central device
and um by integrating uh
advanced manufacturing and also uh small
camera sensors so that you can make a
really small lightful microscopes um
just to make them variable
for
animal imaging in real time and also on
the other hand um yeah we like to see
that at the cellular level um it can
review many of the dynamics or this uh
the structures that haven't been studied
before
due to the spatial temporal compromise
of other types of microscopy tools so i
hope um i mean with live field
microscopy we can we can explore many
unknown regions of biological dynamics
in the future
many thanks again to professors liang
gao and chuzya for their perspectives on
light field microscopy
such a technique requires a powerful yet
flexible camera in order to make the
most of the microscopy benefits
here i'll hand over to my colleague dr
phil allen to discuss good camera
solutions for lightfoot microscopy
imaging systems
hello thanks to the speakers for their
insights into light field microscopy and
thank you matt for the introduction
to all of you i'm phil allen i'm a
product manager for teledyne
photometrics in previous positions i've
been both an academic researcher
building fret-faced biosensors to
address live cell function and manage
several microscopy cores so i've got
quite a interest in microscopy and the
various techniques being applied to it
i want to talk to you today about camera
requirements for light field and some of
our cameras that we think provide unique
solutions for the light field imaging
approach
so to borrow a slide matt used back in
the beginning
just a quick comparison again between
wide field and light field light field
microscopy
steers the photons that originate in
different z positions to different x y
positions on the sensor in contrast
different z positions in wide field just
end up at different blobs when they hit
the sensor but in the same x y center if
our goal is to use light field imaging
as a fast volumetric measure of the
sample we need to collect this data with
precision
speed
and accuracy
so using light field approaches we're
really even much more constrained by the
parameters of the camera than we are
with regular wide field because we need
all the normal requirements of high
sensitivity low noise and appropriate
pixel size to match the optics sampling
but because now we're using multiple
pixels for one point from the sample we
need more pixels and as you've heard
from the speakers the bigger the field
of view of the sensor the more the
sample one can capture
we're also spreading signal from volumes
above and below the focal plane to
multiple pixels reducing the photons
that any one pixel sees
and lastly to recreate the
three-dimensional image from our light
field microscope math has to happen i
won't delve into that i'm in no way an
expert but math can be rather distracted
by noise so the better the signals and
noise of our collected image the better
the result
so with that in mind
i want to introduce you if you don't
know them already of our kinetics family
of cameras and how appropriate they are
for light field the kinetics has the
largest field of view of any scientific
cmos camera on the market with a maximum
quantity efficiency of around 95 percent
and low noise
and it can also do 500 full frames a
second read out of its 10 megapixel
sensor
there's the full kinetics of the 29
millimeter field of view and the
kinetics 22 which has a reduced field of
view more appropriate for those of you
c-mount connections that match the rest
of your optical setup
in the next few slides i'll talk about
some of the ways to use the camera and
compare them with the rest of the
competition
so let's think about field of view i
mentioned a 29.4 millimeter field of
view
so if you think about a classic emcd
electron multiplying ccd or a ccd
they were hard to make big so a common
ccd size is maybe 11 millimeters
the standard scientific cmos stretches
out to about 18 or 19 millimeters
the kinetics and the clinic kinetics 22
stretch out to 22 and 29
so for the kinetics you get 2.4
times the area of a typical cmos 2.4
times the information from your sample
and 6.5 times larger than your emcd so
you've got larger throughput of your
sample
to become
data which ideally becomes results when
you publish your paper so you get to
capture more at every frame
the camera has four modes and we think
these make the camera the most flexible
and the precise camera on the market
so
it has a high dynamic range mode that
can go at 83 full frames per second
that would be 83 full frames per second
in the full-size kinetics with 10
megapixels
has a sensitivity mode for slightly
lower read noise higher collection
efficiency and slightly better speed and
it has speed mode
speed mode is when you really need to
measure fast processes quantitatively
imagine cardiac muscle contraction
imagine voltage changes in neurons as
action potentials run down an axon the
speed mode can go 498 frames per second
and we have a sub-electron readout mode
for those of you who can take the time
to really get very precise data with
less than one electron grid noise about
0.7
so let's think about this again if we
want to look at voltage and detect
action potentials and we'll talk about
this in two of the modes dynamic range
and
speed modes
if you need dynamic range mode because
for example your voltage sensor has very
little contrast very little min max with
the voltage change and therefore you
need to collect a lot of photons to
measure that precisely
in the full frame dynamic range mode
goes 83 full frames a second
what does that
get you how much space from the sensor
can you get if you really want to go at
500.
so if you're a standard cmos you can do
something about this
pretty thin stripe
if you then go to the kinetics in
dynamic range mode it is going to be six
and a half times larger area six and a
half times more rows
so more of your sample
same full well but more sample at 500
frames per second
let's talk about speed mode 500 frames a
second so for a typical cmos
in a fast mode
we get 11 times greater area between the
competition's scmos and the kinetics and
speed mode
so you can see everything your
microscope's outputting not just a thin
strip
and if you remember what our speakers
said in light field imaging the bigger
the sensor the bigger the sample volume
you can measure and so you can see
clearly here you can
get a huge amount of the sample measured
what if we want to go faster than that
500 frames a second
we can start moving towards extreme
speeds
as i said 500 full frames at full 10
megapixels but what if we start reducing
by doing less rows so we could for
example take it down to half the width
and go a thousand two thousand at a
quarter width four thousand at thirty
two hundred
by eight hundred rows and if you really
pushed it down to a two line readout
like a line scan camera you can go
greater than 100 000 frames per second
so let's talk about light field and
region detection light field
imaging results in a bunch of discrete
spots to recreate the sample
sampling may require high speeds but
light field data is not always imaged
across the entire sensor
so
if you could take multiple regions of
interest cartooned here in red
across three cells and collections of
neurons
we could
naively go a lot faster and take a lot
less data
and so i want to tell you
about a pre-beta version of our new
multi-roy functionality
and the idea is this
in our existing cameras you could reduce
data by for example taking these three
blue regions of interest
organized here in two different
configurations
but
if all three regions don't lie on
basically the same amount of rows for
example in this right side cartoon
you have to take all the rows in between
the region and so it gives you what i
call a bounding box constraint you still
have to collect all of the data even if
you're going to throw away what's not in
the region of interest
so you do get a frame rate speed up by
collecting only this red box but it's
not as good as you would get by
collecting this red box
so in our new approach we are going to
be skipping the empty rows and the idea
same cartoon here is we'll create two
regions
we only read out these two regions
and we'll skip regions above and below
that aren't relevant to your science
this feature is actively in development
and current performance allows five
regions of interest that can go the full
width of the sensor
right now we can go up to 50 rows in
each region and with those 50 rows
and five of them
we can go faster than a thousand frames
per second as i said this is currently
in development but we can all start
thinking about what we might do with
something like this
so
we might just
want to reduce data and increase speeds
or we might be able to do something
interesting like maybe we could have a
fast filter switching or different
optical configurations to steer let's
say red up here and green down here
or we could take one of the advances
recently in multi-focal imaging systems
and put one focal depth here and one
focal depth here and i leave that up to
your imagination and please tell us what
you think you might would do with such a
feature like this
so in
summary we might take this region of
interest of our neurons
and be able to sample the network
behavior of these three neurons
with only collecting the region's
interest so we get less data and because
we're only measuring these three regions
and skipping in between we have faster
sampling
so to finish i just want to give you a
quick reminder of the specifications of
the kinetics and the kinetics 22. so a
minimum of a 0.7 electron read noise
95 percent of quantum efficiency in the
peak 3200 by 3200 for the kinetics 2400
by 2400 for the kinetics 22.
six and a half micron pixels these six
and a half micron pixel size is pretty
nice for everything from
60 year so high in a oil immersion
objectives all the way down through 10x
air objectives speeds at 500 hertz at
3200 by 3200 and speed mode and the
field of view is 29 millimeter diagonal
for the kinetics 22 millimeter diagonal
for the kinetics 22. and in my opinion
these are the most flexible powerful
scientific cameras for imaging in the
biosciences and with that i'll hand you
back to my colleague matt who will
finish up our presentation thank you for
your interest
thanks again to phil for taking us
through the benefits of the kinetics
scmos family for light field microscopy
to end i'd just like to highlight how
light field microscopy is on the rise
here we can see a rapid increase in
publications featuring light field
microscopy since its debut in 2006
this increase in research interest is
partly due to the access to new and
improved imaging technologies
teledine photometrics introduced the
world to back illuminated scmos camera
sensors in 2016 with the prime95b the
world's first back illuminated scmos
camera which gave a great benefit to
scmos sensitivity
photometrics then advanced to the next
generation in cmos cameras with the
kinetic cmos in 2019
with these advances in camera
technologies there can also be advances
in microscopy technologies so with the
latest and modern camera technologies
available and constantly improving every
technique serves to reap the benefits of
improved imaging
our guest speakers are also directly and
recently contributing to the rise of
light field microscopy both with recent
publications concerning light field
imaging and the many different
directions this technique can develop in
in summary light field microscopy is a
powerful technique that can produce 3d
volumetric images with a single snapshot
light field imaging therefore excels at
high speed 3d imaging particularly
for
calcium or voltage imaging in organisms
or 3d samples
live fluid microscopy is a powerful and
versatile technique when paired with the
appropriate cmos camera
and the kinetics family presents an
ideal solution for light field
microscopy and much more
i've been dr matthew kozedan from telen
photometrics and i'd like to say many
thanks for attending this webinar on
light field microscopy
have a great day
and thanks again
thank you dr professor gao professor gia
dr allen and dr cosey dunn for your
informative presentation you will now
start the live q a portion for the
webinar with dr cosey done if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for um so our
first question
um
how does the snr trade off
with the fast image acquisition in terms
of the reconstruction
not sure
this is a
this is a great question
because while there are a huge amount of
benefits to this kind of fast volumetric
imaging
it's important to consider that certain
reconstruction methods can amplify noise
so the first thing you have to do
is to make sure that initially
you have as high a signal to noise ratio
as possible so the camera needs to have
as higher qe as possible
in order to maximize signal collection
in the wavelength you're imaging in
and any southern noise
contribution as low as possible this
being read noise shot noise and current
noise because you're imaging so fast
you can only do that if you're so
sensitive so in order to image at the
speeds required for voltage imaging in
the kilohertz or thousands of frames per
second
you'll need
milliseconds of exposure
and if the only way to get these
milliseconds of exposure is to have
a camera that's sensitive enough to pick
up the signal in order to image it at a
high speed
so
maximizing the signal-to-noise ratio
initially at acquisition is very
important and then on the other end it's
important to
consider which deconvolution methods
you're using in order to reconstruct the
image in order to make sure that it's
going to amplify the signal and noise
in the same ratio or that it doesn't
amplify the noise over the top of the
signal so
perhaps you need deconvolution and
reconstruction methods that involve
regularization
or methods that are commonly used by
others using lightfoot microscopy
because the good thing is the majority
of people
will be
encountering the same issues in terms of
computational cost
and
running very fast images over a large
volume but trying to maximize the
signal-to-noise ratio while
reconstructing the final volume
i hope that goes somewhere
thank you
um and then our next question where do
you buy the micro lens array
how does this micro lens array uh
mounted to the camera and what are the
tolerances of this mounting structure
i'm not certain about the specifics of
where to obtain the array and
how
to attach it to the system but it won't
be
on it'll be just before the camera
itself so it'll be
uh if you have a similar optics setup
you'll have maybe some filters or
polarization sections in front of the
camera this is rather similar except
you'll have a lens of microarrays
similar to something you'd use with
a super resolution spinning disk system
where you'd have a micro lens for every
cut out
so
you'd need to get one that matches the
pixel size of your camera best so the
kinetics is around 6.5 micron pixel if
you have a lens
far bigger than that then you're going
to limit your lateral resolution
so
find
one that matches your camera's pixel and
then set it the correct distance away
from the camera as you would with any
other optical systems
but in order to mount it and get the
tolerances off it i'm not entirely sure
but it shouldn't be too dissimilar to
mounting traditional optics or mirrors
on a bench
wonderful thank you
um and then our next audience question
do you use fft for high speed
recognition in your setup
um by fft i i'm assuming it means fast
fourier transform i'm not entirely sure
the camera does have an fpga unit that
can do some processing as the data is
coming onto the camera and then it's
streamed straight to the motherboard by
right to disk
in order to determine if it's
recognizing things at high speed the
camera's doing the vast majority of the
work for you in terms of recognition and
acquisition
later on you have the data with which
you can then
put to more computationally assertive
tasks like uh
refocusing or reconstruction
um but uh the short answer there is i'm
not sure with regards to fft
but i'd be happy to
answer this by email if you get in touch
all right next one we have here what are
the benefits of the multi-roy on
the kinetics
so
uh the kinetics it has a very high speed
across 500 frames across the full sensor
but in order to do things like voltage
imaging you need a much higher speed so
you need to squeeze down the region of
interest a very small area if you're
able to do this multiple times
you're then able to look
more at specific points in your sample
maybe you don't want to look at entire
field it's specific neurons you want to
pick out you can look at very specific
parts of your sample this also works
well for flow or microfluidics you often
have channels you can align your readout
to each different channel and simply
look at particles flow along there
and as phil mentioned the uses are kind
of bounded by your imagination but it's
essentially rather than having one
letterbox you could have say five
letterboxes and you'd maintain the speed
as if it were one
larger letterbox as opposed to one split
into five
but the applications for this uh i'm
really interested to see what people are
going to use it for
okay
thank you and then our second to last
question here does light field
microscopy need speed
uh well with light field microscopy you
are imaging
across a volume and if you're able to
image across the volume normally with
other techniques you'd spend time
imaging so you could then set up a
volume
if you can image a volume in one
snapshot you can also unlock the ability
to image volumes very fast and the main
applications for imaging volumes very
fast would be something like voltage or
calcium imaging
just because you can do live field
doesn't mean you have to go at a rapid
speed
but considering every
every acquisition
acquires a volume it's often paired with
high imaging speed systems so you can
get high speed imaging in volumes
wonderful and then we did get a few more
questions while you were answering that
one
um so the ones that came in um recognize
let's see recognizing on board can
greatly improve the uh thorough put are
you planning to implement such a high
level of api implemented on the hw level
so
we've implemented a number of things
into the fpga of the kinetics uh we
recently partnered with uh dot photons
so that you can have the data compressed
up to seven times as it comes off the
camera so there's definitely a wide
range of applications for how we can use
the processors and the cameras so you
can have these things happen directly in
the hardware and take some of the load
off your computational system
uh as to whether we're planning to do
recognition i'm not entirely sure but
the capability is there for the camera
to take some load off the workload by
having the fpga do that so i'd be more
than happy to get in touch and find out
some more specifics and see if we have
anything in the works or if we can get
something in the works because we're
part of teledyne and therefore paired
with sensor manufacturers and all sorts
of other companies we have the
capability to
produce quite a few of these custom
systems based on
what researchers want to see and what
they want to do
okay great
um and then another one that came in how
fast is the post processing part for
the processing of the image and how
would this relate to on-flight
measurements of single cells
so in terms of 3d processing
i'm not sure
what if this is in terms of
deconvolution it'll mostly be done post
acquisition because there's quite a high
computational load in that you have a
lot of data to push through the camera
in terms of
3d processing the data that comes off
the camera is already capable of being
in 3d
so if you want to do sort of
time on flight measurements of single
cells you can pair light field imaging
with something like flow cytometry and
you can see the cells come through
at the speed you would normally be able
to image that but you'll be able to
process that into a 3d image
after the fact because you have the
directional and perspective data
as to whether you can do it
on demand i'm not entirely sure how long
it would take but other 3d
reconstruction
techniques do seem to be quite
time consuming and
computationally intensive so i think
you'd be able to capture the
image and acquire yourselves moving as
fast as you could in a light field
regime and then you'll be able to
reconstruct the 3d setup of that at the
same speed afterwards so you'd still be
able to image things like single cells
or even voltage at very high speeds in a
volumetric sense without needing to scan
but it wouldn't be coming off the camera
in 3d sense
awesome and then our last question here
are other modes
planned for the kinetics
um so we have a great number of fpga
uh engineers working on different modes
for the kinetics we recently introduced
sub-electron mode
as phil mentioned this allows you to
push the read noise below one electron
and we
have other
um other capabilities in beta such as uh
frame averaging
there's going to be another webinar
later on this year about
scattering techniques and these pair up
very well with
frame averaging that allow you to look
at
multiple frames and average the data
between them as opposed to frame summing
so there's a lot of capability to do the
kinetics and we'll
launch all these capabilities as soon as
we have them so we definitely have more
plan for this platform because it's
proved to be
very powerful and
the more capabilities we can pack into
it the more advanced images can get out
of it essentially
so we have sub-electron mode and we'll
soon be having multi-volume there'll be
other things in the works as well
wonderful
watch dr jose dan do you have any final
comments for our audience
um not as such no i'd like to thank all
of you for coming
it's been great to do this presentation
and learn about these new exciting
techniques that are coming out and
allowing
things to be image that couldn't be
imaged before and new capabilities
we're always
active on social media and on our
website www.photometrics.com
so if you feel like you have a question
that hasn't been answered or you want to
learn more about the technology or learn
more about the cameras please feel free
to get in touch we're more than happy to
chat with anyone and
find out how we can help
but beyond that thank you so much for
coming out today
thank you and thank you again dr um
sorry professor gao professor gia dr
alan and dr
cosey dunn for your time today and your
presentation and we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor teledyne
photometrics for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitting during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time have
a great day goodbye
you